what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about things marvel and
mcu and it appears that chris evans
may not be done with the marvel
cinematic universe and his character
captain america we have some big news
today to break down but first thank you
to skillshare for sponsoring this video
more on them
later things are getting extremely real
with the marvel cinematic universe one
division comes out in about 14 hours if
you plan to watch it at midnight when it
releases
pacific time in the us i'll be doing a
watch party and then a discussion about
the first two episodes after if you
would like to stop by but let's talk
about this
new chris evans captain america back in
the mcu news because of course everybody
is just
absolutely freaking out right now and a
ton of media outlets are reporting this
so let's dive
right into it this report is coming from
deadline.com a very very reliable source
in our industry and the title reads
captain america i's return
to the mcu as chris evans nears deal to
reprise role
in future marvel projects so before we
even get into this article this is
insanely real this isn't some random
rumor coming from somebody on the
internet it's a very legitimate report
coming from a very big
outlet and as we get into the article
deadline says
exclusive report in a move that is sure
to rock the marvel cinematic universe
sources tell deadline that chris evans
is cleaning the dust off his captain
america attire
as he is expected to reprise the role
and the mcu
in some form now they go on to talk
about this so-called deal that chris
evans is signing right now and they say
still vague if deal is completely closed
but insiders say it's headed in the
right direction
for evans to return as steve rogers aka
captain america
and at least one marvel property with
the door
open for a second film this is
absolutely
insane especially when you consider that
in the mcu right now captain america is
very very old
but in the world of the mcu that could
certainly be undone or we could get a
different
version of him since the multiverse is
real in the mcu at least
now they did add sources say it's
unlikely to be a new captain america
film and more likely to be
what robert downey jr did after iron man
3 appearing in films like captain
america civil war and spider-man
homecoming
now how chris evans could return as
captain america is a little bit unclear
right now
but of course i have some theories since
the falcon and the winter soldier is
pretty much
already done with the first series
nothing new to really add at this point
in time since filming is done
he's most likely not going to be
entering that installment
i think that's everybody's first
reaction is to think oh he's going to be
in the falcon in the winter soldier but
his deal isn't done yet
so it's not going to be falcon and the
winter soldier but there is a movie
that has started filming but is
currently on hold due to the pandemic
but a movie nonetheless where everything
is possible and that is
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness now if chris evans is going to
return
as captain america i don't think he
actually would want to play an
alternate version of the character that
he's played for many many years now
but doctor strange is going to have the
time stone again marvel studios has
already alluded that the stones will be
returning and in avengers end game the
ancient one hinted about how important
they are
for reality in the universe that they
know so it looks like doctor strange is
going to get the time stone again
which has the ability to reverse time
for an individual person we saw thanos
do this to vision
an avengers infinity war and if steve is
now in our current timeline like he
showed up at the end of avengers end
game
and he lived his full life and peggy
could be dead
why not put in a fight again after many
many years of being retired and having
the perfect life that you always wanted
maybe after all that he wants to get
back in the game one more time as
captain america
i personally would love to see this but
of course there is the option that he
could be an
alternate version of captain america
universes are going to be colliding in
the mcu
up to doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness and then of course by the
time we get to the film the multiverse
will be
in madness and we'll have multiple
versions of different characters such as
of course all of the spider-man reports
that we have right now
but other characters too such as captain
america and perhaps in another universe
chris evans plays that captain america
as well now captain was the leader of
the original avengers and we know that
there's going to be a new avengers team
coming in and a young avengers team
coming in
so perhaps one of the next projects
coming up has to do with these teams and
that's when they'll put in captain
america
him coming back to kind of motivate them
and set them up but not necessarily be
the leader of them kind of being like
tony stark and the spider-man homecoming
film
he's there for motivation but he isn't
handling all of the work
on top of that there are so many new
disney plus projects and
marvel films coming that he could be a
part of it's captain america he honestly
probably fits into any upcoming project
that marvel has planned but i am curious
as to how
you think he'll return more on that in
just a second i want to say big thank
you to skillshare for sponsoring this
video
killshare has been my go-to this past
year through the pandemic for learning
new skills
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
i have personally used skillshare for
many different things both for work
and for fun i've used skillshare to
learn more about photoshop and how to
make better thumbnails for my videos
and i've also watched videos on how to
edit video footage better
and as i mentioned before i've also been
using it during quarantine to try and
get better at guitar taking classes
if you're looking for a place to explore
your creativity or to simply try to
improve at things such as learning
instruments or learning software
skillshare is the perfect place to learn
all of these things and the great news
is is that the first
thousand of my subscribers to click on
this link in the description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium so you
can explore your creativity and if
you're not one of the first thousands
don't worry it's only ten dollars a
month with an annual subscription so
it's very very affordable
if you're interested in youtube classes
you can check out the teacher sorel
amore
just click the link in the description
down below to get started
so again i want to know how you think
chris evans will return as captain
america in the marvel
cinematic universe where will captain
america come back
will it be a movie will it be a disney
plus show which ones do you think it's
going
to be will it be him or an alternate
version of him
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating
to the marvel cinematic universe for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof